[Applause]
the ladies of the view are together
again co-host whippy goldberg joy behar
sunny hostin and sarah haines all
reunited at the show's new york city
studio for the first time since march
2020.
[Applause]
the reunion comes at a perfect time the
view will be kicking off its historic
25th season on september 7th the show
begins its silver anniversary
celebration with a return to the studio
and the return of the show's live
audience and iconic hot topics table i
can't believe it's 25 years i had i'm
still trying to finish the sentence i
started in 1997.
these are the jokes okay
political commentator anna navarro will
continue in her role as guest co-host
and is set to make regular appearances
throughout the season season 25 will be
the first in a while without megan
mccain the conservative commentator
exited the show in august you know this
has been a really wild ride the past
four years of my life it's been
honestly the best of times and the worst
of times in all ways on and off this
show to fill megan's spots the show
plans to welcome other conservative
voices to guest co-host throughout the
season starting with former utah
congresswoman mia love additional guest
co-hosts appearing in the coming months
include condoleezza rice carly fiorina
gretchen carlson as well as more
familiar faces like the real housewives
of new york's ebony k williams and
former southern charm star cameron
eubanks and get this in honor of the
landmark season the show will welcome
back former co-hosts too they'll revisit
the view on flashback fridays to help
celebrate the show's incredible
milestone that celebration continues
online with a special podcast series
called behind the table we thought we
could celebrate it by bringing back the
people who know it best hello
i miss you guys how are you for a
special podcast series from the view i'm
so glad i did my hair
you'll hear cohost talking about what it
was like to sit around the view table
the podcast will feature women who have
had a seat at the table as they share
never-before-heard stories and reveal
first-hand details behind the headline
making moments that cemented the talk
show in pop culture history these seats
have been filled by such amazing
powerful strong intelligent women
remember the meetings we'd have in my
dressing room that should have been the
show
even jump into stories i've never heard
i went back to my room and she fired me
etie spoke with the view co-host sarah
haines back in 2020 when she returned to
the show after leaving in 2018 to join
good morning america the panelist opened
up about why it was important for her to
return to the iconic round table who
wouldn't want to come back to that round
table it was an honor the first time i
it's it's
again i said it best i think when i said
it's like shooting it's like catching a
shooting star twice i feel
like this was such a gift for me um to
sit next to these people when i when i
got the opportunity to leave i i it was
amazing but to leave the view i had
fallen in love with this place on so
many levels it wasn't just the people at
the table
you